nadine morano vous avez dit sur valérie
pécresse on n'a jamais été les meilleurs
amis du monde mais valérie pécresse est
la meilleure candidate pour la france et
valérie pécresse a dit s'il y avait eu
un prix du courage politique elle
l'aurait donc il ya du respect entre
vous c'est vrai que vous avez dit que
j'aurais j'ai pas donner un césar j'ai
rien donné
nadine morano est-ce que vous soutenez
valérie pécresse bien sûr
vous avez lu la phrase que j'ai dit oui
si je suis là c'est parce que j'apporte
mon soutien total à valérie pécresse
donc pas ce que vous aimez nicolas
sarkozy on l'a pas entendue a apporté
son côté son soutien à valérie blass
invite à regarder l'excellente émission
de m6 chez votre consoeur karine le
marchand je regarde jamais ça
parce que il y avait un portrait des
candidats et candidates pardon pour
mieux les connaître dans leur intimité
et à cette occasion nicolas sarkozy a
apporté son témoignage sur ce qu'il
pense de valérie pas que moi aussi j'ai
apporté mon témoignage à des gens il ya
dix ans mais la lie ce qu'il apporte
également un soutien massif apporté
c'est maya 19 cécile apporter semaine là
non il n'a pas apporté son soutien à
valérie pécresse il ya quelques semaines
il a parlé en des termes élogieux mais
alors que celle qui a été sa ministre ça
n'a rien avancé parlant des termes
élogieux de sa solidité de son
efficacité bien sûr voilà oui bah pour
moi il ya des gens que j'aime beaucoup
mais que ça vaut une forme de soutien
non et non et puis j'ajoute que c'est
dommage vous n'étiez pas là quand il est
venu lui remettre la légion d'honneur
mais lorsqu'il est venu lui remettre
cette décoration il a fait un discours
je pense plus qu'élogieux et pourquoi il
va soutenir emmanuel macron
mais c'est ce qu'on se dit monsieur
hanouna
il faut dire les choses rapidement mais
on est tous les deux nous connaissons
très bien nicolas sarkozy nous avons eu
l'honneur mais d'autres se mettre dans
son gouvernement l'ensemble dans ce
gouvernement et toutes les deux nous
avons été élus toutes les deux en 2002
l'assemblée nationale et donc je connais
valérie depuis l'assemblée dans
lorsqu'elle était parlementaire elle est
devenu ensuite ministre comme je l'étais
nous avons travaillé ensemble je connais
son courage et surtout son efficacité
son pragmatisme à la ronald d enfin on
savait que on a eu des différends on n'a
pas été d'accord sur tout on a eu des
conflits en interne et ça a été publique
1 et je portais la même veste et voyez
je n'ai pas retourné j'aurais pu lui
dire la majorette eux lui dire la même
chose de ses de cette émission que
j'avais dit à l'ats quand j'étais passé
sur sur europe 1 parce que je ne voulais
pas qu'elle parte notre famille
politique et je peux vous dire une chose
c'est que je suis très contente qu'elle
soit revenu parce qu'elle a compris que
l'unité notre famille politique c'était
la seule possibilité pour nous de
pouvoir l'emporter alors aujourd'hui
s'il ya une candidate qui peut battre
manuel mâcon et qui se prend tous les
coups dans la figure c'est valérie
pécresse parce qu'elle incarne cette
droite républicaine avec un programme
extrêmement solide à la fois sur
l'économie sur les retraites écoutez moi
j'entendais ce qui se disait sur les
retraites valérie pourrais vous dire que
lorsque nous étions aux affaires malgré
la crise économique et financière
nous avons fait la réforme des retraites
pour sauver notre régime par répartition
parce que la réalité c'est que si nous
l'avions pas fait aujourd'hui on ne
serait pas en situation de payer les
retraites à tout le monde nous n'avons
pas assez d'actifs pour les nombre de
retraités qui sont aujourd'hui à la
retraite faut dire la vérité aux
français donc nous nous avons eu ce
courage de le faire monsieur macron qui
a présenté pendant trois heures sa
conférence de presse nous explique que
il n'a pas été en situation de mener à
bien la réforme des retraites qu'il
avait promis aux français parce que la
crise du coc vide si c'était vrai il
aurait présenté pendant son projet la
même réforme des retraites or quand il a
présenté sa réforme il dit non mais je
vais changer je vais augmenter l'âge du
départ à la retraite progressivement
c'est à dire qu'il nous copie parce que
sa vraie forme qu'il avait présenté aux
français qu'il n'a pas été fichu de
mettre en oeuvre c'était une usine à gaz
qui n'aurait pas fonctionné que les
français ne voulaient pas donc la
réforme des retraites ou les fêtes sous
nicolas sarkozy bien sûr et à chaque
fois la réformes des rôles est emmanuel
mac on vous dit qu'il n'a pas fait il
allait louis nicollin tuèrent pardon
maintenant il revient sur sa réforme des
retraites il s'était fait ils en
feraient une autre oui c'est ça me dit
georges en frais nôtre mais il n'aura
pas l'occasion d'en faire parce que
j'espère que les français qui nous y
croyait vraiment ben moi je vais vous
dire j'y crois vraiment parce que vous
aviez fait la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy je me rappelle vous étiez il ya
toutes les deux très présente a choisi
la ville avait une équipe d'ailleurs
vraiment qui était derrière nous sommes
mais avec un pécresse a une équipe
solide aussi un oui mais non les fois où
les banquiers pardon aux livres -
olibeau - monsieur qui était sur téva ya
quelques jours la vie et bertrand
meyer plus de 200 parlementaires je sais
mais c'est vrai que je vous dis à
l'époque en 2007 des présidents de
région nicolas sarkozy on sentait
vraiment une équipe derrière lui et non
je vous rappelle qu'en 2012 il y avait
plus grand monde n'y étais avec nadine
mais aujourd'hui est ce que justement
parce que c'est important vous soyez là
nadine aujourd'hui est ce que les gens
de votre camp n'attendent pas un mot de
nicolas sarkozy que nicolas sarkozy dise
clairement où je soutient valérie
pécresse ou bien on entend énormément de
rumeurs disant qu'il va soutenir
emmanuel macron un coûteux arrêter avec
les rumeurs personnel porte parole en
mai et nicolas c'est messi oui mais
personne ne fait rien le fait que laver
je regarde c'est pas bon ça t4 2010 est
il a soutenu françois fillon la dernière
semaine donc là on est à 19 juin oui
mais les six saisons de la sarkozie
d'abord non mais ici c'est pour le faire
le 11 avril par la plana pardon mais bon
moi je pense que nicolas sarkozy vous
c'est abou a d'abord c'est un homme de
conviction oui bien statut particulier
il est l'ancien chef de l'état justement
c'est important nous sommes dans une
période très difficile avec la guerre
entre la russie et l'ukraine qui lui
donne dans son statut un statut en plus
ce qui est différent puisque même ça
c'est blanc bonnet
nous sommes maintenant mais vous savez
nous sommes prêts nous sommes dans une
démocratie dans une démocratie moi je ne
suis pas choqué quand le président de la
république actuel
consultant l'ancien président de la
république pour avoir son opinion sur
ces sujets bien sûr je trouve que c'est
le fondement même du respect
démocratique et de la continuité de
l'état et donc pour l'instant
nicolas sarkozy c'est notre président de
coeur de notre famille politique et
j'espère justement c'est pour ça que son
avis est important que mémé coûté son
avis est important s'ils avaient à
choisir je le dis ils adhérent de notre
famille politique à jour de cotisation
s'il doit choisir entre le programme de
valérie pécresse qui est dans la
continuité de ce qu'il a fait et qui est
régalien et celui d' emmanuel macron
celui du manuel macron mais franchement
pourquoi il le dit pas long mais
emmanuel macron fin honnêtement nous
prouver le ciel
mais le dit croire ont ils cessé savez à
hollywood il serait très bien si c'est
un explique heures en fait c'est l'homme
de netflix et l'épisode un épisode 2 ces
photos noir et blanc hyper sexy ps voilà
allez vous plaît
vous plaît moi moi ce que je veux c'est
moi je suis mère de famille et je suis
grand mère aussi un banc et je sais que
nous avons la responsabilité pour cinq
ans
de porter un programme pour nos enfants
pour nos petits enfants parce que vous
savez gouverner c'est pas gouverner que
pour cinq ans et à court terme c'est
gouverner pour un long terme pour les
générations futures on parlait des
retraites on parle des impôts parle de
l'école valérie a parlé des personnes
handicapées on parle de la dette quand
elle met dans son programme qu'elle veut
mettre en place la règle d'or budgétaire
parce que sa qualité aussi je suis
désolé mais valérie pécresse elle a été
élue présidente de la plus grande région
d'europe
et europe moi je sais je connais un peu
l'europe elle a été élu président de la
plus grande région de rome et surtout
vous savez monsieur hanouna oui madame
vonn elle a été réélue mais c'est vrai
donc quand vous êtes réélu c'est que les
gens pour qui vous avez travaillé vous
donne à nouveau leur confiance et donc
moi je considère que la manière dont l
arrêt j'ai elle a géré cette région ile
de france
est une preuve de sa capacité à être une
excellente gestionnaire et apporter une
vision pour la région et donc moi je
voudrais que cette vision qu'elle à 7
force qui est là et c'est une nécessité
qu'est là parce que c'est pas facile
hein d'être candidate élections
présidentielles vous auriez pu le faire
vous je me sentais pas en situation non
d'accord voilà donc moi je lui reconnais
ce courage et c'est pour ça qu'on doit
tous être derrière elle parce que c'est
trop facile de se dire tiens si on
pouvait jouer la défaite ça je ne
supporte plus la ba oui c'est ça me tue
ça ça m'énerve vous y croyez encore
alors à moi j'y crois mais plus que
jamais arrêté non mais moi je me fous
moi non mais moi oui moi je vois pas de
mal et réputation aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la série ça vous dérange ça
vous dérange cali comment moi j'y crois
pas non mais j'ai aujourd'hui trois
aujourd'hui l'accusé il ya une musique
qui dit c'est fait emmanuel mâcon sera
président qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ça alors d'abord moi je voudrais revenir
je devais revenir sur deux choses qui
sont très importants de kadima évident
parce que et c'est aussi j'aurais dit 4
nacion c'est très important la réforme
des retraites c'est vrai que dans le
programme de macron il ya un peu de
recopiage un peu très peu hein parce que
sur la sécurité n'y a rien sur
l'islamisme et à rien sur les
interrelations n'y a rien sur le travail
et la revalorisation des salaires y à
rien mais je reconnais que il a repris
la réforme des retraites d'ailleurs
débauchage recopiage c'est un peu sa
stratégie mais pourquoi il n'a pas le
faire pourquoi il va pas le faire mais
parce que pour le faire il faut du
courage nous on a fait avec nadine quand
on était au gouvernement des réformes
très courageuse moi par exemple j'ai
fait la réforme des universités pendant
neuf mois il a fallu tenir pour faire
l'autonomie des universités contre des
manifestants gauchiste les amis de
monsieur 85 monsieur roussel qui voulait
pas de l'autonomie des universités
aujourd'hui tout le monde est très
heureux c'est pour ça qu'il faut se
méfier il faut se méfier des réformes
ont dit les français ne veulent pas
l'autonomie des universités il y avait
beaucoup de magnifier eu beaucoup de
matches neuf mois de manifs et tout le
monde m'a dit oh là là c'est terrible
vous êtes en train de détruire
l'université française et bien
aujourd'hui grâce à ça
grâce à cette réforme aujourd'hui on a
des universités dans les dix premières
donc je vous le dis pourquoi grenelle
mâcon enfin la réforme le frère parce
qu'il cède à la rue il cède à la rue
regarder ce qui se passe en corse en
corse pendant cinq ans il a méprisé la
corse les corses les les territoires là
il ya des mouvements encore ce pouf
l'autonomie donc il sait de la rue pour
faire la réforme des retraites il va
falloir beaucoup de courage vous avez vu
que monsieur roussel et monsieur 4 nancy
sont déjà en train de préparer leurs
arguments il y aura ou il faudra
beaucoup de courage mais il faudra le
faire pour sauver les retraites est pas
mentir aux jeunes générations que quand
ils partiront à la retraite eh bien ils
pourront financer leur grand âge
les français veulent à nouveau un bis
repetita
c'est à dire livre non mais revivent
macron le pen dont dont même les vols
agnesi vol qui va le pire alors l'europe
en sa victoire qu'il va le battre a
lancé manuellement je suis et avec
valérie pécresse qui peut les parieurs
hippiques là c'est pour ça que moi ce
que je ne veux pas ce qui est de
dispersion des voix de la droite boyer
et eric eric zemmour est mon ami je le
dis je le réaffirme ici sauf que ce
qu'il propose sont pas des bonnes
solutions même sur la question
migratoire c'est pas une bonne solution
son ministère de l' immigration
je suis désolé ce qu'il faut c'est un
service public de la reconduite au sein
d'un ministère de l'immigration parce
que l'immigration zéro
ça veut dire quoi se dire que là
aujourd'hui avec emmanuel macron la
france est ouverte à tous les vents et
là on aurait une france qui est fermée à
tout le monde est ce qu'on a envie de ça
non non donc moi je dis à tous ceux qui
se sentent de droite qui ont envie d'une
vraie politique ferme sur le régalien
efficace sur l'économie et qui
permettent une bonne gestion des deniers
publics c'est le programme porté par
valérie pécresse et par toute l'équipe
le nom alors moi
c'est un beau message de nadine morano
est ce que vous pensez pas que un
soutien de nicolas sarkozy dans les
prochains jours pourraient avoir une
petite impulsion
valérie
mais vous savez aujourd'hui moi j'étais
très fier d'être ministre avec nadine de
nicolas sarkozy et il m'a beaucoup
appris mais aujourd'hui ce que je crois
c'est que les français ils veulent un ou
une présidente de la république et donc
ils veulent juste savoir ce que j'ai
dans mes tripes ce que j'ai dans le
coeur est et pourquoi je leur dis les
choses pourquoi je leur dis moi je vends
un certain nombre de c est ce que je
vais le faire et nadine l'a très bien
dit la différence entre macro et moi
elle est aussi pardon dans le
tempérament emmanuel macron c'est un
beau parleur ça c'est un beau parleur
j'en sais beaucoup beaucoup de belles
paroles ils recherchent ces dons innés
commerce versace il va continuer mais
qu'est ce qu'il a fait au fond est ce
que la france va mieux aujourd'hui qu'il
ya cinq ans moi ma région elle va mieux
aujourd'hui que avant que je ne suis et
j'ai fait c'est une quine ce que je dis
je le fais c'est donc c'est important
pour les français est ce que vous pensez
que nicolas sarkozy va soutenir valérie
pécresse moi je sais qu'une seule chose
c'est que
je défends de valérie pécresse remplie
qui disent on s'en fout on ne s'en fout
pas messi est désolé non c'est vrai
qu'une semaine on entend que nicolas
sarkozy apporte son soutient emmanuel
macron se serait calmée mais mais mais
franchement
non mais pardon arrête tout le monde le
sait arrêtez de faire des breaks et de
se mentir arrêtez de faire des plans sur
la comète mais bon on verra alors
combien drissi hanouna mois sans
conviction et réagir mais si elle nous
n'avons bien précis on en reparlera les
sirènes ou non moi j'ai une seule
conviction c'est que je pense que
nicolas sarkozy trahira jamais sa
famille politique parce que sans ça
alors
j'ai une conviction
j'ai une conviction sais qu'en disant
rien il trahi sa famille politique je
vous le dis c'est tout si on dit rien
c'est qu'on ne soutient pas on va pas se
mentir c'est vrai c'est pas tout à fait
part ainsi à bompas qu'ils n'ont de la
politique non non c'est bon non mais
c'est vrai en tout cas moi j'ai une
femme quitte récente pas très bien bravo
vous avez bien raison